este vídeo ha sido una petición expresa
de todos los miembros de la comunidad de
visual politiken patrón así que está
particularmente dedicado a todos
vosotros una vez más muchas gracias un
millón de gracias por apoyar este
proyecto y para los que no seis miembros
de patrimoni queréis más información os
dejo un link en la descripción
arranquemos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
un vasto continente repleto de riquezas
y una población en rápida expansión el
último continente en sumarse a la
modernidad una tierra de oportunidades
infinitas un territorio en el que la
república popular china ha depositado su
atención y sobre el que ha volcado su
capital ahora el dinero y las empresas
chinas fluyen abiertamente por este
continente algo que está generando
muchas preocupaciones en occidente
queridos amigos amigas de visual
político durante las últimas décadas en
el panorama económico y social de áfrica
comenzó a cambiar de la desesperación se
pasó a un optimismo casi total un
optimismo feroz e irrefrenable desde el
año 2000 al 2018 la pobreza extrema se
redujo más de un 30 por ciento la
esperanza media de vida creció en más de
10 años y la mortalidad infantil se
redujo a la mitad además algunas
economías comenzaron a experimentar una
evolución tan rápida que se hicieron con
su propia etiqueta los leones africanos
de repente el último continente el
continente olvidado estaba comenzando a
despegar así que como no contagiarse de
ilusión cuando por fin por fin áfrica
estaba lista para comenzar la carrera
por la modernidad sin un momento porque
la pandemia del sars coronavirus 2 ha
supuesto un duro golpe y no me refiero
sólo al impacto sanitario
en medio de tanta euforia los proyectos
de inversión comenzaron a crecer como
setas en todo el continente claro que la
inversión la inversión hay que
financiarla pero como áfrica estaba
creciendo eso ya no era un problema todo
lo contrario con los tipos de interés
por los suelos en los países
desarrollados muchos organismos y
entidades de todo el mundo empezaron a
canalizar más y más flujos de capital
hacia áfrica lo que hizo que en pocos
años se duplicará la deuda externa del
continente
no era un problema si lo podían permitir
las economías crecían tanto que la deuda
externa no suponía ningún peso en
términos relativos de hecho para muchos
países su situación aparentemente
incluso mejoró pero claro con el impacto
de la pandemia ese escenario se dio la
vuelta por completo de la noche a la
mañana
[Música]
y de repente áfrica se enfrentó a su
primera recesión desde comienzos del
nuevo siglo la pobreza comenzó a
repuntar y muchos gobiernos comenzaron a
tener serios problemas para hacer frente
a los pagos de la deuda y no sólo eso la
propia pandemia hizo crecer el gasto al
tiempo que redujo los ingresos lo que
multiplicó las necesidades financieras
de muchos estados algo que hizo que la
deuda pública tal y como podéis ver en
pantalla repuntará con fuerza
para colmo las agencias de calificación
redujeron la calificación crediticia de
un montón de países hasta el punto de
que hoy el 93% de los gobiernos
africanos evaluados por estas agencias
se encuentran por debajo del grado de
inversión es decir su deuda es
considerada como 'bonos basura' lo que
significa mucho menos dinero disponible
y dinero mucho más caro
amigos hablamos de un problema de deuda
un problema que podría llegado el caso
derivar en toda una crisis financiera y
económica países tan prósperos durante
las últimas décadas como kenia etiopía o
camerún han empezado a tener algunos
problemas y amigos aquí han saltado
todas las alarmas primero por el riesgo
de que se desaten nuevas crisis
humanitarias en áfrica y segundo por el
riesgo geopolítico que conlleva porque
si hablamos de deuda y áfrica tenemos
que hablar necesariamente de china por
ejemplo el propio gobierno de los eeuu
en tiempos de la administración trump
llegó a denunciar el uso perverso por
parte de la república popular china de
la conocida como diplomacia de la trampa
de la deuda ahora bien que de verdad en
todo esto hasta dónde llegan las
intenciones de china de qué demonios
está hablando el gobierno de eeuu atento
esto un momento antes de continuar
habéis escuchado hablar de la carne
cultivada en laboratorios de la
tecnología de la rn mensajero o de los
viajes espaciales queridos amigos amigas
nuestro mundo está cambiando a toda
velocidad y la pregunta es qué demonios
significa esto para los inversores pues
si quieres saber más sobre todos estos
temas no te pierdas como invertir en el
futuro el último vídeo de si lo hubiera
sabido el canal de actualidad financiera
de motivos con el que participamos os
dejo el enlace en la descripción pero
dicho esto continuamos con áfrica china
y la llamada trampa de la deuda atentos
la compra china de áfrica
[Música]
desde que llegó al poder áfrica ha
cobrado cada vez más y más pensó en la
diplomacia china tan solo como
presidente del gigante asiático además
de impulsar foros y espacios de reunión
por aquí y por allá el líder chino ha
realizado cuatro giras por el continente
así que podemos decir que la presencia
de xi jinping en áfrica ha sido mucho
mayor que la de cualquier otro gran
líder internacional y eso eso se nota la
política china ha seguido amigos los
pasos de los crecientes lazos económicos
que unen a china con áfrica o quizás ha
sido la economía quien ha seguido a la
política que fue antes el huevo o la
gallina el caso es que desde el año 2000
el comercio de china con áfrica se
incrementado en más del 2000 por cien
hasta superar los 200 mil millones de
dólares en 2019 y eso eso no es todo si
en 2006 había 800 empresas estatales
chinas operando en el continente
africano hoy son más de 10.000 las
empresas públicas y privadas que están
presentes lo que ha hecho que china se
convierta también junto a reino unido y
francia- en el mayor inversor
internacional en la región
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea el 40% del
mercado de las infraestructuras un
porcentaje muy alto de la actividad
minera y más del 12 por ciento de toda
la producción industrial de áfrica está
ya en manos de empresas chinas
empresas como transition el fabricante
de móviles con sede en shenzhen que
lidera el mercado africano y coopera
fábricas locales fábricas como la que en
2011 abrió en addis abeba la capital de
etiopía en la que fabrica más de un
millón de terminales móviles cada año
hablamos de una exposición que no para
de crecer apuestas como por ejemplo la
que el 21 de septiembre de 2021 presentó
el propio embajador chino en nigeria
cuando anunció que se estaba ultimando
el desembarco por la puerta grande de
algunos de los bancos más grandes de
china en el país africano
china elegido nigeria por una razón
específica el petróleo nigeria como
estado miembro de la opep registra sus
ventas de petróleo en dólares esta
medida tiene el objetivo de persuadir al
sector energético de nigeria para que
acepte pagos en yuanes por su petróleo
arthur don profesor de estrategia y
economía de la universidad de georgetown
queridos amigos amigas chinas ha
convertido en el mayor prestamista
extranjero de toda áfrica según la
iniciativa áfrica china de la
universidad john hopkins tan sólo los
préstamos oficiales del gobierno y las
grandes empresas públicas del país
sumaron más de 150 mil millones de
dólares entre los años 2000 y 2018
por ejemplo durante las últimas dos
décadas china ha financiado uno de cada
cinco proyectos de infraestructuras en
todo el continente y ojo porque muchos
de estos préstamos cuyas cláusulas y
condiciones concretas son secretas por
exigencia expresa de pekín incluyen
según parece activos estratégicos
soberanos como garantía o incluso el
pago con materias primas este podría ser
por ejemplo el caso de angola el país
que con mucha diferencia más préstamos
ha recibido de china y cuya devolución
se estaría realizando en gran medida con
barriles de petróleo algo que tal y como
veremos puede ser uno de los grandes
objetivos de la potencia asiática
pero sobre la deuda con china fijaos en
lo que decía el mismísimo ministro de
finanzas de uganda en una carta del 2018
dirigida al presidente museveni dado lo
que está ocurriendo en nuestros países
pares en lo que respecta a la deuda de
china creemos firmemente que debemos
proteger nuestros activos de una posible
incautación mattia casa ella ministro de
finanzas de uganda en 2018 así que
teniendo todo esto en cuenta creo que
hay unas cuantas preguntas que debemos
hacernos que busca exactamente china en
áfrica existe la trampa de la deuda qué
implicaciones tiene para el continente
africano todo este proceso que hemos
descrito atentos
[Música]
trampa de la deuda
la pregunta la gran pregunta que creo
todos podemos hacernos es qué demonios
busca china qué precio exige realmente a
cambio de su apoyo financiero y no no me
estoy refiriendo al tipo de interés en
2017 la administración trump comenzó a
poner sobre la mesa la idea de la trampa
de la deuda según este planteamiento el
gobierno chino estaría básicamente
promoviendo la entrega de préstamos
oficiales a países en vías de desarrollo
con el objetivo esencial de endeudar los
hasta el cuello para así tenerlos
controlados y poder sacar tajada es
decir lograr concesiones así que no sé
para ver si esto tiene un sentido si os
parece vamos a cambiar ligeramente la
pregunta de estar en lo cierto qué
beneficios podría obtener exactamente
china vale creo que el primero de todos
de ellos es muy evidente china devora
materias primas y si algo tiene áfrica
esos son precisamente recursos naturales
[Música]
más de una tercera parte de todo el
petróleo que importa o el 20% del
algodón que consume la industria textil
china procede de áfrica y todo eso por
no hablar de recursos como el manganeso
esencial para la producción de acero o
el coltán vital para la industria
electrónica y cuyas mayores reservas se
encuentran
precisamente en este continente y estos
son solo cuatro ejemplos de una larga
lista ya podríamos poner sobre la mesa
[Música]
de esta forma los préstamos podrían
tener una doble función por un lado
construir las infraestructuras que la
propia china necesita para poder
explotar todos esos recursos y por otro
tener pillados a los gobiernos para
controlar esos recursos pero más allá de
esta cuestión si algo destacado
últimamente es el rédito político si lo
habéis escuchado bien el uso político de
la deuda a cambio de una mejora de las
condiciones o de una extensión de los
plazos de pago fijado
[Música]
en 2020 de los 53 países que firmaron
una declaración de apoyo a china en el
consejo de derechos humanos de la onu
tras la aprobación de la ley de
seguridad nacional en hong kong 25 eran
africanos y otros tres grandes países
geria sudáfrica y kenia aunque no la
secundaron tampoco se sumaron a las
críticas contra pekín y exactamente lo
mismo ocurrió con las denuncias contra
la persecución a los uigures y otras
minorías étnicas muchos países africanos
han apoyado a china en los organismos
internacionales
asimismo por otro lado los votos de los
países africanos también están
respaldando la elección de
representantes chinos para dirigir
importantes instituciones
internacionales como es el caso de la
organización de naciones unidas para la
alimentación y la agricultura dirigida
desde 2019 con un representante del
gobierno chino gracias en buena medida a
los votos africanos
es evidente que todo esto está
ocurriendo la deuda concedida a los
gobiernos africanos le da a pekín una
enorme ventaja a la hora de negociar
pero es esta toda la historia áfrica
necesita capital necesita
infraestructuras necesita inversiones y
hay china podría estar jugando un papel
muy pero que muy importante porque la
pregunta que podemos hacernos es ha
mejorado o no ha mejorado áfrica durante
las últimas dos décadas
[Música]
no creo que haya un plan deliberado por
parte de china para endeudar a ningún
país creo que china está cumpliendo un
papel muy importante que es en términos
de apoyo a la infraestructura a kings
umía de sina presidente del banco
africano de desarrollo además por mucho
que hablemos de la trampa de la deuda y
por mucho que nos digan desde washington
no podemos obviar una realidad la
república popular china se ha convertido
sigue en el mayor prestamista pero ni
mucho menos en el único
ah
china controla aproximadamente en torno
al 25 por ciento de la deuda externa de
áfrica lo cual es mucho sí pero también
quiere decir que el 75% restante está en
manos de otros países u organismos tan
solo el banco mundial y el fmi tienen
casi tanto peso en la deuda de áfrica
como china solo zambia yibutí y la
república democrática del congo tienen
la mayor parte de su deuda en manos
chinas
[Música]
pero recapitulemos china está sacando
tajada política de sus crecientes
relaciones con áfrica pero aparentemente
áfrica necesita las inversiones chinas
sin embargo un momento amigos porque hay
otro factor a tener en cuenta no todo es
tan sencillo si nada financia lo que le
da la gana lo que está muy bien es
completamente lógico pero tenemos que
tenerlo claro china financia lo que le
da la gana
[Música]
y sabéis que quizás el problema está en
que muchos de los proyectos impulsados
no tengan sentido económico que es
exactamente lo que ha ocurrido en la
mismísima china por ejemplo un estudio
de la universidad de oxford en 2016
determinó que más de la mitad de todos
los proyectos de infraestructuras
realizados en china durante las últimas
tres décadas han tenido un rendimiento
por los suelos según este estudio de
hecho sólo el 28 por ciento de los
proyectos podrían ser considerados
económicamente interesantes en otras
palabras y si es el modelo chino lo que
no funciona porque el gobierno chino
amigos genera los suficientes recursos
como para lo que se derrochar en
infraestructuras sobredimensionadas o
innecesarias pero ese no es el caso de
los gobiernos africanos quizás eso sí
sea una consecuencia no buscada de la
deuda china mucho ojito con esta
cuestión
si los proyectos tienen pobres
rendimientos económicos quiere decir que
pueden no generar lo suficiente como
para devolver la deuda claro que no
tiene por qué ser así áfrica necesita
inversiones eso está claro y nadie
hubiera podido esperar el impacto del
coronavirus por supuesto queda claro que
la inversión extranjera directa puede
ser mejor que la mera financiación y
también está claro que pekín utilizará
todos los instrumentos a su alcance para
obtener ventajas políticas aunque ello
suponga hacer tratos con líderes
corruptos y firmar préstamos para fines
o estimables pero amigos si hay algún
responsable en última instancia esos son
los líderes africanos en cualquier caso
seamos optimistas el capital construido
prevalece china está muy interesada en
que áfrica prospere y ahora todo apunta
que entramos en un ciclo de precios de
las materias primas al alza
[Música]
un ciclo que puede darle al continente
africano los recursos que necesita para
superar el golpe de la pandemia y volver
a la senda de crecimiento que ha
mantenido durante los últimos 20 años no
sé personalmente qué queréis que os diga
puede que exista la diplomacia de la
deuda pero creo que no conviene exagerar
ni ver fantasmas por todas las esquinas
si preocupa la presencia china en áfrica
lo que tendrán que hacer los gobiernos
occidentales digo yo es buscar las
fórmulas para mejorar la inversión en
este continente y la integración de los
países africanos en la economía mundial
no sé es sólo una opinión mi opinión así
que ahora turno para ti crees que china
realmente está empleando la deuda
estrictamente como arma política y crees
que tienen que hacer las potencias
occidentales deberían combatir
contrarrestar la creciente influencia
china en áfrica déjanos tus respuestas
por aquí abajo en los comentarios y como
siempre si este vídeo te resulta
interesante no olvides darle al botón de
like suscribirte abisal polític si es
que aún no lo has hecho muchísimas
gracias a todos los patrones que nos
habéis apoyado y habéis hecho posible
este vídeo un abrazo y hasta la próxima
[Música]